[Music]
not such a great debate last night huh
what did you think what do you think
that was yeah a lot of people very
disappointed about that debate a lot of
people disappointed in President Obama's
performance last night last night
critics say President Obama spent too
much time looking down at something on
the podium did you notice that yeah and
today the president apologized said at
the next debate
no more Angry Birds he did well
apparently I had to stop doing it here
because I was missing everything is that
what you've been doing at one point last
night President Obama said the one thing
about being president is learning to say
no yeah especially when someone asks do
you feel ready for this debate
Mitt Romney went after PBS last night
it's about time someone went after those
guys it's about time someone took some
starch out of their cup I'll get you
Reading Rainbow
during last night's debate Mitt Romney
said he would cut funds to PBS even
though he loves Big Bird yeah he said
he's definitely against whatever the
hell Bert and Ernie are up to it goes
against God the for the debate last
night there was a coin toss to see which
candidate would speak first yeah there
was an awkward moment just before the
coin toss when Romney asked what's that
shiny little disc you're holding it
amuses me there was one point for the
debate Mitt Romney said if you're over
60 you can stop listening now yeah -
which moderator Jim Lehrer said then I
should have stopped listening 40 years
ago did it seem not since you like he
was in a well or something during that
debate yeah he was just surrounded by
darkness and occasionally they lower a
bucket yeah yeah yeah it's almost like
all non sequiturs from a hat book there
[ __ ] your Ted Kennedy impression yeah
yep I'm just gonna stand here until you
tell another joke I'm not gonna do it
there is some exciting news though from
the world of television I don't know
last night's debate
you know some people like it some people
didn't but there's this exciting news
the final season of Jersey Shore
premieres tonight final season yeah yeah
I don't want to spoil anything but after
this season no one in the cast ever
works again citing rock news rap groups
Public Enemy and NWA have been nominated
for the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame yeah
the group said nothing helps their fight
against white power structure like
getting a plaque at a museum in
Cleveland hey this is just seeing ladies
cadbury has come out with a candy bar
specifically designed to appeal to women
it's called chocolate you know I want to
mention this is cool news from it from
the world of science some experts say
that this week television broadcasts may
be occasionally interrupted by bursts of
radiation from the Sun yeah so if you're
watching my show right now and you see
something large orange and incredibly
hot that's just me
[Music]
that made me sad at the end that that's
a joke Jenna and gentlemen check this
out
a man in Florida was arrested for having
sex for the second time with his
neighbor's horse
apparently this this guy just can't take
nay for an answer
[Music]
I went to college